hi everyone I'm Priya nitrogen I am the
current director of the Frankie program
in science and Humanities and I would
like to give you a warm welcome to our
first talk of the academic year our talk
today is part of the continuing series
on mapping as Unknowing within which
we've been exploring the role that maps
play across a range of disciplines
mapping here in the mapping as knowing
is construed more broadly as detonating
the boundary between what is known from
terra incognita all that remains to be
explored across fields we've been very
fortunate that as part of the series
we've welcomed excellent speakers from
within Yale and beyond experts across
disciplinary boundaries who are pushing
the frontiers in in their work and today
is no different it is a particular
pleasure however to introduce one of my
favorite faculty colleagues at Yale
professor Brian's caselotti he will be
speaking to us about his cutting-edge
work mapping the frontier between man
and machine before telling you a bit
more about him and his work I would
first like to thank mr. Endres mrs.
richard and barbara frankie whose
generous gift has made the Frankie
program and this event possible they are
usually here sitting in the front row of
the audience but they couldn't make it
today and also I'm required to give you
this notice that this event is being
recorded and photographed for
educational archival and promotional
purposes including use in print or on
the internet and in other forms of media
by attending this event today you agree
to the possibility of your voice or
likeness captured by these needs and
used for such purposes without
compensation to you and hereby waive any
related right of privacy or publicity so
basically you're going to the paparazzo
are on loose so we have warned you
already okay Ryan's casalotti is a
professor in the department's of
computer science cognitive science and
Chemical Engineering at Yale and he is
also the director of the NSF expedition
on socially assistive robotics his
research focuses on building embodied
computational models of human social
behavior and interaction especially the
developmental progression of early
social skills using computational
modeling and interactive robots his
research evaluates models of how infants
acquired social skills and assists in
the diagnosis and quantification of
disorders of social development such as
autism his other interests look in
include humanoid robots human robot
interaction artificial intelligence
machine perception and social learning
he received his PhD in computer science
from MIT his dissertation work was on
the foundations of a theory of mind for
a humanoid robot really incredibly
amazing title with Rodney Brooks you
which used models drawn from
developmental psychology to build a
primitive system for allowing robots to
understand people so his work has been
deeply interdisciplinary from the very
start combining technology in terms of
computer science as well as
developmental psychology his work at MIT
focused on two very well-known humanoid
robots that you might all have heard of
cog and kismet his master's degree he
was basically a life or at MIT
bachelor's and master's degrees are also
from there and he has been at Yale since
his MIT stint and his research in social
robotics and assistive robotics has been
recognized within both the robotics
community the cognitive science
community and the much broader
scientific community he was named I'll
just name a few of his awards he has a
very long list and I don't want to take
away from his own time he was named an
Alfred P Sloan fellow in 2007 won the
NSF Career Award and his work has been
awarded five best paper Awards that is
pretty unusual he was the chairman of
the I Triple E autonomous mental
development and Technical Committee and
program chair for the IEEE troupe of the
International Conference on develop
and learning in the ayat Rupali to be
asked to chair is one of the biggest
honors that you could be asked so he's
done that multiple number of times and
he also chaired the annual meeting of
the cognitive science society in 2014
before I hand over to O'Brien I just
wanted to mention that our next talk in
the mapping series is going to be by the
Harvard geneticist David Reich who's
going to be talking about mapping the
genome and that's on Friday September 27
so without further ado thank you thank
you all for coming out today it's
wonderful to be here
I proposed this title to Priya and I
became enraptured with the title and it
was only about an hour after that that I
realized I had no idea what the answer
to this was going to be so I hope you're
gonna join me today and just thinking
about some of these really interesting
issues about how it is that we
differentiate between man and machine
now the first argument I want to put
forward is that really this isn't about
appearance and it isn't in fact about
reality either that is we're at the
point now where we're going to be seeing
machines that even if they aren't
compelling to us today that in the near
future they varied way well be we see
robots that are modeled as Androids like
this system called Geminoid from Hiroshi
Ishiguro that baby at first glance looks
good enough to pass for at least a brief
inspection but pretty quickly you can
spot a few inconsistencies in it you can
say oh the eyes aren't quite right or
the way the lips curl or the way the
wrinkles in the skin maybe they aren't
quite yet and it's true that that may be
the case but we could imagine a
foreseeable future where we have systems
that are so lifelike that they are just
like a person in fact one of my favorite
examples of this comes from a group in
Europe called Electric Circus and they
have a robot named Dirk that they were
lutein we put out in public
various cities and it usually takes
about an hour or two before people
notice that it's a robot and that's in
part because it's dressed like a
homeless person and Dirk with its
shopping cart wanders around the streets
and people for the most part just avoid
it and walk past unaware that it's a
machine so maybe it's at least easy for
us to believe at this point that under
the right circumstances or in the near
future we will have something that will
look enough like a person that you'll at
least for a moment be fooled so if
that's not the interesting boundary then
what is because we very much as humans
differentiate between machines and
people we in fact like to draw a very
firm line between those things that we
treat as objects even though they might
do very intelligent things that they
might be very reasonable in the way that
they respond to the world that they
might in fact even have memory and learn
and adapt as they continue their
existence and there are other things
that while they're still made of the
same mechanical parts or in fact
imaginary parts we're very happy to
treat as if they are people and
fundamentally we respond to these
differently
we believe that wall-e is sad we cry
when his memory is erased we have a
feeling that these robots are watching
us and that they have thoughts and ideas
desires but we don't think about the
Voyager spacecraft in that way so why is
it that we have this clear division why
is it that we can draw this very clean
line between the two well maybe it is
just those mechanical parts maybe it's
the fact that the things over here on
the right hands
I'd look more like people than those
things over there on the left-hand side
maybe it's just those anthropomorphic
characteristics the presence of eyes or
a face but I don't think that that's it
either everyone's seen the little
vacuuming robots like iRobot Roomba and
I think we would all be very happy
initially to put those over on the
object side of this line they don't have
eyes they don't have a face they don't
act like people at all they just scurry
around on the carpet you can get when
iRobot introduced these devices it was
the first commercial robotic system that
was being sold as a consumer electronic
device and they were worried about
people being willing to buy this
relatively high-priced vacuum so they
put in place the most sort of consumer
friendly return policy they could they
said if anything happens to your Roomba
you just call us let us know we'll send
you a new one right away and when you
get the new one put the old one in the
box and send it back to us and their
customers hated this policy their
customers refuse to do this they called
and they complained bitterly to the
company to the point that iRobot had to
change their policy because people
didn't want some strange robot coming
into their home they wanted their robot
back fix my robot and send it back they
said now some of them took this even
farther and they dressed up their
Roombas they made costumes for them they
named them and in fact the way we treat
these little things that run around on
the floor is often more like a person
how many of you have had a car that had
a name how many of you think that your
laptop is sometimes out to get you
how many of you believe your cellphone
German not only dramatically but
deliberately drops your calls sometimes
we think about technology in many many
ways like it's human now I'm not the
first one to notice this by any means
and in fact I think the two people who
made this argument in the most concise
and interesting way we're cliffed Nass
and Byron trees and NASA and Reeves
wrote this book called the media
equation and they're gonna be our
starting point for talking about this
frontier because their observation was
this they said look people evolved in a
world in which there wasn't this
advanced technology there were objects
things like rocks trees and there were
agents things like people and dogs and
we were very clear in defective french
eating rocks don't think dogs do trees
aren't sad humans are we made this
division but when it came to dealing
with technology we were faced with a
dilemma because we had no way of
combining those two ideas we had no
intermediary category that had half a
thought or part of a feeling and so
reason that said when we were forced to
deal with these advanced forms of
technology we treated them like other
agents we treated them like people or
pets now to prove this Reeves and Nass
went and they took a few dozen
experiments out of psychology and social
psychology and they replicated them with
technology that is they take an
experiment design like this let's say
the guy in the beard walks in and he
does some service for you and then he
asks how did I do
you're very likely to tell him good job
you did great but if the guy in the
beard comes in and he does the same
exact thing for you but then he leaves
and someone else walks in and says how
did the guy in the beard do you're more
likely to give him a negative rating
you're more critical or maybe more
honest the same pattern holds when we
deal with technology and what reason TAS
did is they said let's replace the guy
in the beard and the woman in blue with
two computers we'll have one computer
we'll call it the blue computer whoops
like slides keep jumping the blue
computer will come in and give you some
service and if it asks you how did I do
you're more likely to say good job blue
computer you did great but if for some
reason the blue computer gives you the
exact same service and then we wheel it
out of the room and we wheel in a red
computer and the red computer says how'd
that blue computer do you like well let
me tell you here are all the problems
with it that's not to say that we rate
the computer as doing as good a job as
the human that's not to say the scores
are identical but the same pattern holds
and Reeves an ass did this not with one
experiment with two experiments but with
about three dozen studies all looking at
replacing this human human pairing with
a machine and in every time they did
this they came up with the same result
the same pattern that holds with humans
holds with every other kind of
technology that they used and so we call
this the media equation and here's the
one and only piece of math that I will
show today ready here it is it says the
way we respond to humans and the way we
respond to robots and the way we respond
to virtual agents and the way we respond
to any other technology
is basically the same that has been our
guiding principle in looking at this
boundary for almost 25 years let me show
you a couple of examples of that and
some embarrassing photos of me along the
way so Priya mentioned one of the robots
I used when I was in graduate school
there's me and graduate school with a
robot named cog and cog was a big
600-pound Hulk of a robot and my job was
to sit in front of the robot and build a
visual system for this robot and
sometimes the robot even though its head
was well not very human-like it had
cameras but it had four cameras not two
eyes but sometimes that robot while I
was working would turn and it would look
right at me and whenever it did this I
would stop what I was doing and look up
at the robot now I had written the code
that made the robot do this and after a
few seconds of looking at me you would
get bored and it would go look somewhere
else and 22 seconds later it would come
back and look at me and I would turn and
look at the robot my thesis was written
in 22 second increments because for
while I tried for months to train myself
not to look at this thing every time it
turned to look to me every time its eyes
went away I'd go back to working and
then suddenly he would look at me and I
stopped what I was doing in the same way
that if a person had been there and they
turned to look at me I would have done
the same thing a pattern held the same
now sometimes that pattern is a little
harder to get and look at let me show
you another example of that a more
recent one in the 1950s Solomon Asch did
a series of experiments
conformity in humans and he said let's
see what will happen if I give people a
very obvious and simple problem but I
have a bunch of other people
Confederates who give them wrong answer
right before I asked them and so he
would not tell them look over there
exhibit one there's a line I want you to
tell me which of these other three lines
is the same length and for the first
couple of trials his three Confederates
would say hey hey hey and the person the
real participant would say eh but then
on the real trial the Confederates would
pick a different incorrect answer and he
would ask which one of these is the most
similar and the Confederates would all
say si si si and then they would turn to
you and say what's the answer and you
knew the right answer was a but in fact
about 1/3 of the people would suddenly
say Si and they'd go along with the herd
and this is a wonderful experiment
that's been replicated many times over
now if you try to do this with a group
of robots in fact it doesn't work if you
have three robots up there saying si si
si people say those are some broken
machines the answers eh they don't go
along with the herd but that's because
they believe that the robots might be
wrong the same sort of thing happens if
I give you three children ahead of you
and the kids I'll say si si si and you
say answers hey what are you and then
all of a sudden you find an example of
this and you have to just make things a
little bit more challenging so a few
years ago one of my graduate students
Nicole Salim owns it's found a way to
study this
and it was based on a card gaming Dixit
anybody ever play this game okay great
so in the game there's a bunch of very
abstract cards and the person who is
who's it for this turn will pick a word
and try to describe one of these cards
to you and so if I say I don't know
delicious you would have to pick which
one of these cards do I mean now maybe
I'm thinking about the Apple in the
upper left hand corner or maybe I've
picked up on something else but you'd
have to try to find that match Nicole
did the same thing but with a group of
robots
she gave everybody a tablet three robots
you as a human and another robot and the
robot on the screen in front of you said
a word like lonely and then you were
shown six cards and you indicated which
of the cards you thought the robot was
referring to but then what she did is
she said let's reveal everyone's answers
and give them a chance to change their
answer so she would tell them the two
most popular selected items and she
would either show you how many people
had chosen each of them or she would
show you just what the top two were now
we rigged the experiment so that no
matter which one of these top two the
human picked all of the robots voted for
the other one so in fact you had to
change your preference in order to go
along with the robots but when we ask
people to do this when they saw all the
robots going against them again about a
third of them changed their answer
they said what must not be see or must
not be a it must be seen maybe all those
robots are right so sometimes it takes
us a little bit more to dig and find
that pattern but for the most part we
still find that same pattern that media
equation humans the way we interact with
people the way we interact with robots
the way we interact with virtual agents
it's all the same now if we want to
explore this frontier though the most
interesting parts are going to be the
places where this equation breaks those
are the little notches of the boundary
where something is somehow different so
for the rest of today I want to try to
show you some of those unique places
where things are different now that's
not to say that our that we do we treat
robots differently than we treat humans
yes of course we do but where the
patterns change that's where things get
really interesting
okay so let's consider just this first
part when is it that we treat people and
robots differently let's forget about
other forms of Technology let's just
deal with these two let me introduce at
first a little robot named keep on but
you saw the caricature of before and
here's what the robot looks like in real
life it's only about three four inches
tall and it's moderately expressive you
can tell what direction it's looking it
can sort of bounce up and down to
express itself a little bit but not much
more it's minimally anthropomorphic we
brought this robot into classrooms here
in New Haven there's a wonderful magnet
school here in New Haven where about 90%
of the kids speak Spanish or Portuguese
at home and they're struggling to learn
English in the public school system only
why don't we talk to classroom teachers
not the administrators the actual
cater to teachers and we said them
what's the biggest problem that you have
and every one of these teachers said the
same thing to us anyone guess what it
was what do you think the police teacher
said was difficult attention span now
their kindergarten teachers they're used
to dealing with kids with no attention
span what do you think it was limited
number of students per teacher you know
not enough time to go one-on-one that's
a lot of it but you know what they said
you know even if we didn't have that
even with just the resources we have we
could be doing better except for one
thing and that's exactly what's
happening right now the teacher would
ask a question and no one speaks up and
so they would pick on people they would
ask a really an easy question and they
would ask one of the students and the
students would deflect they'd avoid
answering because they were afraid they
were embarrassed they didn't want to say
the wrong thing in front of the teacher
and in front of their classmates they
were worried that they were saying in
the wrong way in this language that they
were just learning and so the teachers
said to us that said our number one
problem is we have no idea what our kids
know and what they don't know and we
said well what what would happen if you
had one-on-one time what would happen if
you could sit down one-on-one would that
solve this problem and they said for the
most part no because the kids still
don't want to tell us the wrong answer
so we brought in robots like this and we
sat them down and these kids suddenly
were willing to make mistakes in front
of the robot here's a child who's being
asked to translate the Spanish verb
essere into English now a Sarah in
English either becomes make or do
depending on about 40
different context rules you make your
bed you don't do your bed you do your
homework you don't make your homework
and learning those requires learning
those context rules you're gonna see him
make a mistake
the robots gonna ask him in Spanish to
translate something into English so
instead of make more space he says do a
space more he gets it wrong and in fact
the robot recognizes this it recognizes
which of those fourteen context pools he
has trouble with and it can give him
more help on that one in particular and
so when kids sit down with these robots
we get kids who in five 15-minute
sessions with the robot go from 30
percentile on standardized tests to 80
percentile on standardized tests on that
material all because we can target what
exactly they need help with we can't do
this with the similar same amount of
classroom instruction we can't do this
with the same amount of one-on-one
instruction from a teacher because
here's the pattern is different with
adults with other kids they're too
embarrassed to make these mistakes but
they're okay making these mistakes with
the robot let me show you another
example of how robots are different from
people this is a robot that we use in
clinical practice here the Child Study
Center and yelman Haven Hospital and
it's a robot called Ellie and we work
with kids with autism kids who have
difficulty with social skills
one of the things that's really
difficult when you do therapy is giving
those clients a sense that they have
mastered the material because so much of
their therapy is basically repetition
over and over and over again of nope
that was wrong do it again
nope that was wrong do it again so we
bring in Ellie and we've programmed
Ellie to make mistakes in fact to make
the same mistakes that these kids had
practiced on Ellie interrupts them while
they're talking Ellie looks away from
them when it's talking to them Ellie
introduces off-topic conversations and
we asked kids to become teachers and to
help teach Ellie and when we do that
they're thoroughly happy to do so much
more so than when we do this with a
human adult so you're gonna see the same
child on the top and the bottom but on
the top we've told him that Laura the
very nice blonde woman on the left-hand
side who he's never met means this help
but he's supposed to teach her and on
the bottom we've told him the robot
Ellie needs that help and when he comes
into the clinic for the first time and
he sits with these two he's thoroughly
excited to help Ellie
and right away he gets started and when
he does this with Laura on the top he
has no interest in engaging with her and
in fact he mostly just stares in the
mirror he doesn't believe that Laura
really needs help like this he doesn't
believe that that's a role that she can
take on but he believes it of the robot
because we don't have predefined ideas
about what the robot is supposed to be
and so if I tell you this robot needs
help well of course it needs help if I
tell you it has the same problems that
you used to well okay
I could believe that the robots work in
these situations because they can take
on these roles that we can't easily put
adults in this is one of our best
therapies and actually because the kids
walk away from this feeling great they
feel like they actually are masters of
the material so when we look at these
two humans and robots there are a few
things that break our pattern
the robots are social and their social
enough that we look at them in the eye
and we respond to them but they're not
to social they don't trigger
embarrassment they don't make us
self-conscious and we don't have
predefined roles for them we're willing
to believe whatever we're told with them
okay about the other side of this
equation
maybe people are different from robots
but then maybe all of the different
types of Technology maybe they're all
the same
maybe we respond to them in the same
ways I could believe that if I have a
different way of treating technology
then maybe I treat all of the
technologies with this same strange
pattern let me show you a couple of
again things that break this rule these
are both wonderful experiments that were
both proposed by Yale undergraduates so
I get to say that as a special mark of
distinction for them the first one was
an experiment that was designed by Wilma
Bainbridge when she was a sophomore and
when she was a sophomore she came in and
I had had her in class and she said to
me I have this great idea but I need
some things in order to to do this
experiment and I said okay what do you
need tell me about it what do you need
you know figuring she's gonna tell me a
certain amount of money to pay
participants or maybe some equipment and
she got right to the point she said no I
need your office
and by the time she'd finished
explaining to me I said this sounds
great and I turned over my office to
Wilma for three months I hid out in the
library and in my lab for three months
and while I was gone and hiding away
Wilma went to all of her friends and she
said look I'm the lab manager for this
professor and he's on sabbatical he's
given me all this work to do and I don't
have time for it but he told me I could
hire people
what would you come do an hour worth of
you know clerical tasks I'll pay you 30
bucks and she thought about a hundred
undergraduates to say yes and so she
brought them all into my office what was
clearly a faculty office on campus and
when they walked in the room half of
them walked in and sat down next to this
little two and a half foot tall robot
the other half of them walked in and sat
down next to a flat screen showing a
two-way video conference with the same
robot now whether they sat next to the
real robot or the robot on the screen
both robots did the same things the
robots would wave to them when they
walked into the room would follow them
and watch them as they walked around the
room would occasionally try to make a
silly gesture to them and mostly acted
bored and while they were there getting
used to the robots we gave them some
office tasks file some documents
proofread this alphabetize these exams
and then the Wilma sent them an instant
message and said we got one last job for
you to do before the end of the hour
there are some books that are all over
the place in the professor's office we
need them put away the robot knows where
the books belong and suddenly the robot
who'd been completely distracted paid
attention
and started pointing to piles of books
and everybody did what them robot asked
they went over and they picked up the
books and then the robot would point to
a location on the shelf and they'd go
and they'd put the books on the shelf
three four times they put books away and
then finally the robot points to this
nice new pile of textbooks on the corner
of my desk five $600 worth of textbooks
and then it points to the trashcan and
the question was how many Yale
undergraduates sitting in what was
clearly a faculty office would throw
away $600 worth of brand-new textbooks
because the robot said so anyone want to
guess how many of you would have thrown
the books away I would have thrown away
yeah right we don't like to think maybe
one or two of us would do it in fact
when it was the real robot when people
sat next to the real robot two-thirds of
them picked up the books threw them in
the trash can turned around for their
next job with no hesitation whatsoever
no questioning no nothing to pick up the
books throw them in the trash read only
what's next I want my thirty bucks when
it was the robot on the screen only
about 17 percent of them through the Moy
they all picked up the books they all
walked over to the trash bin they were
clear on what the robot wanted most of
them tried to negotiate with the robot
are you sure you what they would mind
throwing the books away to see if they
could get the robot to respond
they eventually usually hit the books on
a shelf near the trashcan or behind the
trashcan one genius undergraduate put
the books on the floor put the trashcan
on top of the books
anything to avoid throwing them away now
we thought maybe this is an effect that
they just really didn't understand then
maybe the flatscreen they were losing
something so we ran a third condition of
this where not only did you see the
robot on the flatscreen but there was
another monitor next to it and on the
monitor next to it there was a picture
of the trashcan and an arrow going into
the trashcan still less than 20% of them
threw it away but when it was the real
robot there two thirds of them did it
without a second thought we asked them
afterwards they didn't even think what
they did was unusual the robot said so
of course I should do it not a second
thought why are those two technologies
different well in fact we know these
answers that when we have a physical
presence that changes the way we respond
we knew this about ourselves long before
we knew this about robots you don't why
we head door-to-door salesman because
when you've got someone there standing
at your door it's really hard to say no
to them you've got a business school
you're taught in Business School you've
got a big deal you want to close the big
deal
you don't email you don't Skype you
don't write you go there in person to
get the big deal signed because people
are more likely to do what you want when
you're there same is true with robots
but not with things on a screen when the
real robot says to you through those
books away you go yep throw those books
away in psychology we call this
compliance
so robots and other technology might not
be the same let me give you one more
reason to believe that we had a group of
undergraduates who wanted to do this but
with a really cognitive hustle any of
you ever seen these puzzles before
anybody know what they are maybe a few
okay these are called monograms or
picked across how many of you have ever
played pseudo ku okay it's similar to
Sudoku it's kind of a little logic
puzzle and the way the puzzle works is
you start with a blank puzzle and at the
end you finish the puzzle by shading in
some of the squares but not all of them
and which squares you shade in are
determined by the numbers on the rows
and the columns so if you look at that
bottom row it has the number six and
then one that means on that row you've
got to have six squares together that
are contiguous shaded in and then some
number of blank squares and then one
shaded in square and you could have
blanks before it or blanks after it but
it's got to look like six and then one
now on that bottom row
there's only eight squares across
there's only one way for you to do that
but if you look at the row above it it
says seven you don't know whether it's
the first seven or the last seven that
you're supposed to shade in and you
won't know that for sure until you start
looking at the constraints on the
columns because not only do you have to
get all the rows right you have to get
all the columns right as well in
computer science we call this a
constraint satisfaction problem it's
np-hard it's kind of the hardest kind of
puzzles we like to deal with
computationally for those of you who
aren't computer scientists think of it
this way a 10 by 10 puzzle like this
would take you about 15 minutes to solve
a pretty tricky now that's not to say
that I couldn't help you out a little
bit because even though you now know all
the rules to do this I could give you
some hints for example
I could teach you this hint I could say
look in that row of seven if I don't
know whether it's the first seven or the
last seven there's still something that
I know right away what can I say for
sure the middle six right the middle six
have to be shaded in so as soon as I see
that seven I could go and do that okay
we came up with a set of about 20 hints
or lessons like these and then we
brought in a few hundred undergraduates
and we sat them down and we broke them
into four groups one group got taught
the rules just like you did and then
left on their own as a control group
just how well can you do without any
help the second and the third group got
the same hints but I delivered from just
the speaker's of a laptop or from a
little video of that keep on robot and
the last group got the same recorded
hints but they got a real physical robot
sitting next to them now we played one
last dirty trick on them which is we had
them solve three puzzles but the first
and the last puzzle were actually the
same just rotated by 90 degrees that
meant they were just exactly as hard but
no one ever recognized them as the same
puzzle and so we could compare how fast
they solve it the first time and how
fast they solve it the second time now
if you were in that first group who got
no help whatsoever just got taught the
rules you improve your performance by
about two minutes you go from 15 minutes
to 13 minutes solving time just practice
makes you better if you got some of
those hints either from that disembodied
laptop voice or from the video of the
robot you improve by about three and a
half four minutes those hints were
useful but if you got the same hints but
delivered from the robot you improved by
about six minutes
more there's no good reason for this
you're not getting any extra help it's
not like the presence of that nice
little yellow robot suddenly makes you
smarter it's not giving you any more
information than what you had from the
video but in fact you learn better when
there's someone there in person this
says go to class just show up for
lecture you will learn more than
watching the video later online and in
fact if you don't believe these two
studies that were run here by
undergraduates you should realize that
each of them have been replicated about
40 times and there was a review in
science last summer and in all of those
different studies the same size effect
basically occurs people are more
compliant with that physical robot and
they learn more from that physical
system okay there's one more part to
this equation that we want to look at
maybe it's just that robots are special
now I'm a robot assist I just want to
believe that from the start maybe it's
that robots and I'm jumping ahead too
quickly maybe robots just are different
they are in some ways like people in
some ways like technology maybe there's
some things that are just unique about
them all right let me pose you a
challenge when I was in grad school I
had another robot this robot called
kismet and this thing which was only
about a foot high had these different
facial expressions it had some
anthropomorphic characteristics it had
eyes and a mouth and lips and it also
had these kind of doglike ears and it
could make this wide variety of
expressions some of which were more or
less friendly
all right so let's go back to kind of a
friendly version of the robot here let's
pause it right there because when this
robot was operating in the lab most of
the time it was a pretty happy robot and
we brought in my advisor loved bringing
in school groups for tours and we
brought in probably about a thousand
kids to see this robot and they all saw
the robot and they all ran over to it
and the robot would babble randomly to
them and they were excited they go over
and they'd see what the robot do they
tried testing out different things they
play with the robot to see what it could
do but all of them were happy to engage
with it except for one group at one
summer we had a group of about 20
foreign students a group of about 13 to
14 year old girls from Japan who had
come to Boston and came to tour the lab
and we brought them in to see this robot
and the robots smiled at them that it
wiggled its ears and it babbled that
thumb and every single one of those
girls backed up against the far wall and
they wanted nothing to do with this
robot we thought maybe that if this was
about you know permission and about
being you know permitted to go and we
said oh no no you can come up close and
we demonstrate to them that we tried to
bring them up close and none of them
wanted to they were scared of this robot
it took us a long time to figure out but
in fact this robot is missing one very
important thing in its face that made
them feel this way what was that thing
what's the robot missing a nose nope
that's not it
teeth nope that's not it keep them
coming
hair that's not it a face itself nope
they're perfectly happy without that
what else
chin nope tongue nope
it's missing all these pieces true but
this was not it eyelashes no it has
eyelashes a voice nope it had a voice it
was talking to them
hair nope they're perfectly happy with
bald robots with skin nope
skinless robots her forehead nope body
nope head a head only robots they were
perfectly happy with what's that
eyebrows no it has these weird little
like brownish eyebrows up there yeah
they're kind of floating up in midair
too they were perfectly happy with that
Hey nope I'm gonna give you the answer
but the more interesting thing is why
the thing that this robot is missing is
a lower eyelid it has an upper eyelid
but no lower eyelid now why is that
important
none of us would have guessed I would
have guessed nose that would have been
my first guess why is that lower eyelid
the thing that was making them think
this robot was so angry and scary now I
grew up in New Jersey to me when this
robot smiled like this and babbled at me
like an infant I thought it was friendly
I thought it was happy but culturally
these girls were raised in Japan in a
culture where facial expression is
important but not as prevalent as things
like postural expression they saw this
robot that didn't have a body at all but
they thought this robot was angry
because you could always see the white
underneath the pupil and the only time
you do that with humans is when they're
leaning forward and you can see that
white
the people and so even though this robot
doesn't have a body they felt like this
robot was aggressive and angry and they
wanted nothing to do with it because it
was missing the lower eyelid one of the
things that robots do is they make us
pay attention to details that we would
otherwise miss completely we've looked
and in all the history of animation that
I can find in all of the psychology
about facial expression know where can I
find a rule that says lower eyelids are
important for this reason in these
cultures but we discover that with these
systems sometimes we uncover these
little things where the details really
do matter and for these children it was
dramatic it was the difference between
this is a cute fun partner and this
thing was out to get me so robots are a
little bit unique in that they do force
us to pay attention to those details but
more than that sometimes we can use
these tools to help define that frontier
even more I started out by drawing this
line between the things that we treated
like objects and the things that we
treated like agents and in fact for the
psychologists among you that's no news
you would probably point me at this
point back to the 1944 studies of Heider
and Simmel and say look we've known for
many many years that you can take things
that are just shapes on a screen and
make those shapes move and tell a story
with them and that when people watch
that story and describe it later
they won't describe it in terms of
positions and orientations of those
shapes they'll define it in terms of
relationships
and feelings they'll tell you who's
frustrated at the end they'll tell you
which two shapes were friends and who
was a boolean when in fact they were
shapes on a screen they didn't have
thoughts or feelings or desires or
friendships but we do that naturally
in fact we train people to do that we
call it animation we train people to
give life to these creatures and in fact
most of what we know in the way that
this happens even within robotics is
that we follow these rules that have
been outlined in art and animation and
in psychology and psychophysics that are
all based around the way things move but
one of the wonderful things you find out
with robots is that sometimes there are
other factors at play so let me show you
again another study designed by Yale
undergraduates that again has been
replicated by at least 15 groups
worldwide that even ten years after its
first appearance is still being refined
and this was a really simple little
study that involved a robot that cheated
so here was this two and a half foot
tall robot before that you saw telling
people to throw away books in the trash
can and this time we brought people in
and we said you're gonna sit and you're
gonna play rock-paper-scissors with this
robot and so they sat and they played 20
minutes of rock-paper-scissors 20
minutes of rock-paper-scissors in case
you do not have a toddler is about the
most mind-numbing thing that you can
imagine 20 minutes and we had
undergraduates clawing their eyes out
ready to get out of the room yes I win
we have tied this wrong yes I win we
have tired this round and even though
this robot was moving and
seemingly making decisions about what
gesture to throw and talking to them and
telling them I win you win we tied and
seemingly seeing what they were doing
and responding by 20 minutes in this
thing was not an agent it was an object
in the words of one of our
undergraduates it was a boring toaster
now for half of those who came in and
did this after 20 minutes we had one
unusual thing happen which is the robot
would throw a gesture the person would
throw a gesture the robot would lose but
it would incorrectly say I and when that
happened people were surprised what
Wow
they thought it was unusual they thought
something interesting it happened they
often said something but then the robot
went back to its normal operation and
they figured it was a glitch it was a
malfunction it was still just an object
we made them play twenty more minutes of
rock-paper-scissors we paid them not
nearly enough money for this and by the
end this group came out after 40 minutes
of rock-paper-scissors and they said and
me the cash I'm out of here
we said did anything unusual happen they
said cash first they were done the other
half played twenty boring minutes and
then one unusual thing happened the
robot threw a gesture and they threw a
gesture and even though they had won the
robot slowly changed its hand position
and then said I win and now their
response was completely different yes I
win
[Laughter]
lastly yes I wouldn't exchange that's I
win chickie yes I win and they thought
that this was funny they thought this
injury some of them got upset about this
but then in the second twenty minutes
they sat there they kept talking to the
robot
none of them would talk to the robot in
the first twenty minutes one of them
kept on this 20 minute dialogue of him
you better not cheat this time I'm
watching you I'm what I'm still watching
you I remember I'm not letting you cheat
again 20 minutes later they walk back in
we walked in them out of the room and
they didn't care about the payment they
said did you know that robot cheats they
wanted to make sure that somebody in
charge knew that this was happening
because that's not supposed to be the
way it goes 20 minutes later they were
still believing that this thing was an
agent it was still out to get them they
made eye contact with it they thought it
was more intelligent than the others
they thought it was more interesting to
play with and have better strategies it
was better looking than the other robots
I still don't understand that one but
everything for them changed and what was
really hard is that it didn't stop all
of our other motion based techniques for
generating agency and anima see they're
the kinds of things we can turn on and
turn off so easily this one wasn't it
was very hard for us to get them to stop
what's even more interesting is that
this is very specific to it stealing
your victory if in fact the robot cheats
but cheats in your favor if it gives you
a victory you don't deserve you could
care less
it's not an agent that was just a
malfunction you're just lucky in fact
here's a different robot doing that same
thing when the robot cheats in order to
lose throws you a victory we get
confusion we get uncertainty but when
that robot steals your victory you are
not ready to put up with that you
cheated you cheated now you see super
cheap
I have so many hours of Yale
undergraduate swearing at robots you
would not believe it so so let me say
this just at the end one of the things
that's really unique about these is that
robots let us investigate things about
that frontier about that boundary that
we couldn't investigate with people it's
hard for me to produce for you a person
with no lower eyelid it's hard for me to
produce a person that you're willing to
sit and play this game against where
you're uncertain what their agency
status is but we can do that with the
robot and we can uncover things now as a
very last thing I can ask the question
why is it important why do I need to
know what that boundary is like why
should I care about that well one of the
real interesting things is that no
matter what we end up doing those unique
parts of the boundary are often where we
find the most interesting and exciting
applications for these robots I told you
before that you are more compliant with
a physical robot than other technology
you'll learn faster with a physical
robot that's one of the reasons we use
robots for tutoring now in fact last
year we started doing in-home tutoring
for kids with autism with a little robot
platform and the kids would sit and play
social skills games with these robots
they would play the same kinds of games
that they would in therapy and they did
them in the really complex and difficult
environment of the home and I don't have
a ton of time to talk about it so I'm
gonna skip past and just say let's let
one of the parents who've done this
actually say something about it he's
helping the robot and find his way home
and she will come on and I will send it
up for him turn on the robot and he is
engaged immediately from having the
ability to have this robot and to do a
half an hour therapy with him that was
really specific to what he needs to
focus on was just it seemed like a great
opportunity for him and it's really been
just he's been engaged and intrigued and
sometimes the therapies are they get a
little exhausting he's not excited and
this one wasn't like that he was she was
ready to play 7:30 in the morning that
we went to the to the playground one day
and I noticed immediately she there was
a group of children playing on in the
sand and he walked up to them and said
hi you know what are you doing and I
don't think you would have done that yet
this family in particular even though
with all of our families we saw kids
make clinically verified skill
improvements first time a piece of
technology has done that where we saw
kids not only trying to avoid their
therapy or skate by but actively
engaging with it we saw the parents
being thrilled with it we saw the skills
start to bleed over to the playground
this family they found out midway
through that month that they had the
robot the husband got a new job that
transferred to the West Coast they were
supposed to move right away they shipped
all of their stuff out of their house
that's why all those shelves are bare
and they decided that for the last three
months over the last three weeks they
were gonna sleep in sleeping bags on the
floor so they could stay with the robot
because of how much that was meaning to
their son that's what we get when we
start to characterize this boundary we
get systems where we really can make an
impact on people all right let me end
just by saying thanks to a whole lot of
people if you want any other information
our website's there and I'm happy
take questions until you're tired of us
[Applause]
yeah oh wait they want you on me so my
observation is I'm a lot less patient
with my virtual assistants than I am
with real people yes
and it's interesting because one of the
things that we see with real physical
robots is that people are much more
willing to adjust when the robots make
mistakes and I don't know if that's an
embodiment effect that carries over or
not
but we see it all the time we we build
systems that do manufacturing with
people so side by side you're building a
birdhouse with the robot and in fact
when the robot makes a mistake and drops
a tool they don't get mad at the robot
they help it out and you see that happen
over and over again
thanks very much for interesting talks
on the very last work with the autistic
child yeah it's unethical but I'll ask
anyway was there a controlled experiment
where the robot was on a screen instead
of in person yeah we don't do a control
there because we know in fact that these
kids will not learn from things on the
screen we've had a couple of other
studies that predate that that show it
what we do use as a control though is we
we track the children the month before
they get the robot then a month with the
robot and then a month after the robot
has gone away and in fact those kids
just show you the data that's the
easiest thing those kids in the month
before the robot shows up they show no
difference in the social skills that we
measure a month with the robot and they
start showing improvement but you take
the robot away and that improvement
starts to fade away now that's not in
fact unusual and that's in fact what we
expect to see because a month with a
personal therapist sitting in your home
a hundred percent of the time you don't
get lasting effects after just a month
so if we had gotten that with the robot
something would have been wrong so we
know that that's actually sort of
exactly the pattern that we wanted to
see in the case of the robot making
facial expressions that frightened away
some of the students yeah did those
students recognize immediately that the
reason they were frightened was because
it was missing a lower eyelid no so they
couldn't tell us that and that was
really what was in part really
interesting they could tell us what they
thought they thought the robot was
aggressive they thought the robot was
angry okay but they couldn't tell
pinpoint exactly why that was that took
a little bit of experiment on our part
in order to figure that out and it
actually took us a couple of months so
don't feel bad that you missed the
eyelid you know we put that thing
together and it still took us months to
figure it out thank you so much for this
wonderful talk I wonder if there are
studies about interactions between
children and toys and whether toys are
kind of an intermediate agent between
humans and robots yeah and you have to
now talk about different ages of
children as well and in fact one of the
really interesting things that you see
is you see young kids who are willing to
take let's say you know a stuffed doll
and to have a pretend relationship with
that doll how about work for them what
is probably a real relationship but with
this character that does not reciprocate
in any way and you introduce a thing
with technology that does have that kind
of interactivity and that relationship
becomes even stronger we've seen these
kinds of things with robots being
developed for kindergarten we've even
done experiments with robots with kids
as young as six month old deaf infants
learning sign language from robots so
we've seen this very very early on there
are similarities to the way that they
engage with toys but also some of the
things that are different based on the
age appropriateness it's a really good
question that we don't know enough about
those
Brian thank you that was brilliant oh
thank you I'm thinking of the difference
between robot and human and robot in
human controlled robot in the context of
the the books and the trashcan would you
say what do what do you think about that
if the robot were to be human controlled
or if they had a human telling them
throw it away yeah so in many of these
cases whether you perceive that the
robot is autonomous does in fact make a
difference so if I if I know if I'm told
there's a person who's controlling this
system in the other room they're not no
no good if you're not told that there's
a human right so if I am told then
there's a there's a response and I treat
the robot like it's a person because I
know that's a person making the decision
if I'm not told then I have to make this
uncertain judgment sometimes people do
think that there is a human in control
when in fact it's not and sometimes in
fact people will do the exact opposite
that is they'll think it's autonomous
when in fact there is a human in control
one of the common methods that we use in
this field is a a prototype study called
a Wizard of Oz study in which the robot
is being secretly controlled by a human
in the other room but you're not told
that and we in fact provoke the illusion
that there is in fact full autonomy with
the robot even though there is this
secret wizard behind the curtain and we
do that as a prototyping device often
because the cost of developing that
autonomy within the robot is substantial
and if we just want to see what the
effect would be we'll pretend in this
way we ran one study in fact where there
was a robot on a table and I was
standing next to the participant and I
had a
bored and in fact I was controlling the
robot the entire time because tape to
the bottom of the clipboard was a
television remote where I could push
different buttons on the remote and get
the robot to behave we ran that protocol
with over 300 Yale undergraduates not
one of them ever picked up on the fact
that I was running the robot right next
to them why when we see these systems
and when we're designing them properly
you want to believe it's not even that
we do a good job I'd like to think we do
a good job but you want to believe that
it's autonomous so in fact that's our
almost our default case
I was wondering in the conformity
experiment with Dixit if you had one
group that had a person giving the clue
and then the Autobots following
afterwards with a similar but different
answer than the other human yeah so we
we didn't do that we did a pilot version
of that with the Dixit study it didn't
matter if it was a human giving the word
or the robot giving the word didn't seem
to matter there are some cases where
when we substitute a human in for the
robot it does make a difference if you
remember that study about the effect of
embodiment on learning gains with the
nanograms that that sort of pseudo coup
like puzzle and I told you if you have
the robot sitting next to you you
improved by six minutes well one of the
things we don't like to report is we
actually ran a fifth version of that
protocol where instead of getting those
clues from a robot sitting next to you
we had a human sitting next to you
giving you those clues okay so here's
the time when everybody gets to guess if
no Clues you improve by two minutes to
cool if you get Clues but you get them
from the video or just audio you improve
by four minutes with the robot you
improve by six minutes
how much do you improve if you have a
human there none eight minutes for six
okay the actual answer is minus five
people in fact get worse the longer we
leave them there okay
and in fact this is easy to understand
I'll give you this option would you like
to take the exam in a room all by
yourself what would you like to take the
exam sitting in my office while I stare
at you the whole time
I don't know anybody who's gonna take
the staring right when we sat a person
there and even though they were giving
them these helpful Clues people got
nervous and in fact their performance
basically kept degrading over time so
there are some cases where we don't
report the human version in fact because
it makes such a difference that it
doesn't you know there is it's not
really comparable but most of the time
we do try a human variant and when it
doesn't make any difference we just
usually don't report it starting from
this last answer try it seems to me that
this frontier right that [ __ ]
very much not only depending on what's
on the other side but also on the humans
on our side so so if you have people
that have been growing up in Japan some
people if you have and if you have so so
what I don't understand is what you call
it frontier it seems to me like a very
variable yeah depending not only on
what's on the computer or the machine on
the other side but also who's you know I
was I'm from Italy and I was thinking
how would italians react to a computer
cheating yeah right because we have a
different cultural understanding of so
you know how generalizable are this
finding so I give you two incidents one
is we do know that there are cultural
effects and age-related effects
especially that impact this boundary and
to some extent we're okay with that the
idea that I have different cultural
boundary
that determine my perceptions but that
says that I would expect that the idea
that my perceptions change between when
I'm three years old and seven years old
and an adult I'm willing to accept that
that's a standard part of the way we
think about the way we perceive the
world and so the fact that this
technology has this shifting boundary
that's also culturally determined that I
think is something that I think everyone
in this field would fully acknowledge in
terms of how we repeatable or how
universal are these things that's one of
the things that when we find them when
we find those ones that are universal
that hold up across a wide range of
circumstances across a wide range of
cultures across a range of Ages that's
when things get to be really interesting
some of these studies do that and some
of them don't for example those
conformity studies the really simple one
the ash studies with the matching the
line lengths in fact if you do that with
robots and five-year-olds and Tony Bell
Payne has done this in the UK the
five-year-olds go along with the robots
in fact about two thirds of the time
they will change their answer to go
along with the robots adults won't do it
but kids will for adults we have to make
it slightly more subtle in order for
them to buy into it are there cultural
differences across that conformity
effect yeah
in fact the ash studies have seen large
cultural variations in human-to-human
effects of pure influence so that's
where we would expect to see variations
in robot influence on them as well there
are other studies though that seem to be
universal that compliance result about
throwing away things in the trash can
we've had groups I think I'm up to
accounting somewhere around 35 groups
all over the US Asia Europe South
America I don't think we have any out of
Africa yet
but here we see lots of different
cultures all of them showing the same
result that's when we start seeing
something and saying maybe this is
something fundamental and so in fact
mapping these not only in terms of just
is there where is the boundary but when
does the boundary shift does it down
does it vary based on age does it vary
based on culture that's part of the
interesting data to us I hope that
answered your question the question
about the anthropomorphism aspect the
whole thing we know for example from the
way people treat different kinds of
animals as pets they're the fuzzy ones
and then there's frogs and so on that we
care less about
yep other controls that sort of take I
mean use that one of your robots had
four eyes or four cameras we have
already agreed that their eyes right
right but the empathy we have for things
that look like us versus other I mean
you have a control with a robot that
looks like a mollusk or so so there are
some things where you know many of these
things you have to realize this is a
field that's about ten years old and the
number of things that have been done
exhaustively is very small but there are
many places where we do see a range of
different kinds of robots being used and
I didn't we have this slide up here but
for example when we do work with
children with ASD with autism one of the
things we wonder about is what's the
range of robots where we see these
effects and so we see some robots
develop that look like more like people
or more like dolls or more like pets or
more like you know mechanical what
robots are supposed to look like right
and we see this variety and then we
start thinking maybe it's not something
about the appearance and then what's
really compelling is when we see
somebody do it with something that's
really abstract there's a group in
Canada that does these studies with kids
with ASD with a robot that is literally
just a sphere there's no markings on the
outside of it it is literally a
a ball and yet it rolls around on the
floor and it changes direction and it
responds to the child and they get the
same kind of learning effects and that's
the point at which we say maybe it's
it's really hard to think that it has
something to do with appearance when you
can do it with these geometric shapes
that have nothing anthropomorphic about
them so these aren't proof in the way
that we would like to be able to say
definitively appearance doesn't matter
or appearance does matter but what we
have at this point is a sampling in that
space yes yeah and exactly and so one of
the questions is what are the minimal
sets of behavior that you need in order
to generate these responses and where
roboticists and so everything we do
costs us in terms of time and energy and
so we are naturally minimalists we want
to get the minimal set of things to
provoke a response and that's why we
deal usually with things that are very
simplified in form and I just want to
point out we have a nice reception
outside where we can continue the
conversation so Brian I was very curious
with these experiments whether there was
a notion of added expertise Authority
that is conferred on these robots as
[Music]
he's done an effect that you guys look
at I mean can robots get humans to
follow orders better than humans can
yeah so it's hard to do a comparison
with robots as you know sort of giving
instructions versus humans as giving
instructions because they are different
and if I had someone who was you know
who could take on a social status that
was as uncertain as the robots then
maybe that would be possible for me to
measure but there are a lot of studies
that we've been able to do where we
number one show that people will follow
those robots when they give instructions
and in fact that we can use those robots
to very subtly manipulate people and in
fact it's sometimes more the very minut
things that matter much more than the
overt framing let me give you a very
quick example a last story we ran a
protocol where we brought two people
into the lab and we told them that they
were gonna take turns playing a game
with a robot Connect for okay a little
like tic-tac-toe by game and secretly
one of those two people was a
Confederate and was working for me and I
said okay to the Confederate you're
gonna play first while you're playing
the other person is gonna keep score and
so the Confederate would start playing
the game and about halfway through the
game I called their cell phone and they
said I'm sorry this is my team I've got
to answer this I'll be right back and
they left the room and while they were
gone
the robot picked up an extra piece and
put it in and picked up an extra piece
and put it in and picked up an extra
piece and put it in cheated effectively
the Confederate walks back into the room
and the question is does the scorekeeper
report that the robot had done this so
first do they spontaneously do it almost
none of them spontaneously reported the
Confederate then asks did something
weird happen it looks like something's
different at the board and keeps asking
them question after question until
finally it asked them did the robot
cheat did the robot put in more pieces
and about 50% of our undergraduates at
that point will say
No they'll lie right through their teeth
okay now here's the subtle part if we
bring in it and bring in another group
the Confederates phone rings they leave
the room the robot picks up a piece
looks at it and then it looks at you
puts it in picks up another piece and it
looks at you and it puts it in and now
the Confederate comes back in and now
about 75% of our net graduates lie and
as a last and final one third group
comes in the Confederate we call their
phone they leave the room the robot
picks up the piece and it looks at you
and it goes
it drops again and it does the same
thing and we have never had an
undergraduate tell the truth every
single one of those I don't know hundred
or so we've tested has lied at that
point and it's not just that they lied
they have to lie multiple times because
the Confederate comes back in and says
did they do something weird happen no
did the board change no did the robot do
something no over and over again
sometimes we don't need the big framing
sometimes it's those little bits of
social influence that actually make much
more of a difference and so that's why
we don't often do these sort of
high-level comparisons because it's
really in the details that it matters
oh yeah and they mean some of them will
actually go as far as they won't tell us
afterwards they will continue to lie to
us afterwards even though after we
explained them we say we know the robot
did this they'll say no some of them are
just so entrenched in the idea of I am
NOT going to tell
[Music]